have you ever thought about it how it
changes the Dynamics of relationships
because when you think about it if
you're okay if you're in a deal right
with someone and one party gains
everything by leaving and one party
loses everything by Leading leaving the
person that loses everything is always
going to be trying to appease the one
that gains everything and so and so I
feel like that's why we get we get
um phrases like she wears the pants in
the relationship yeah because having a
wife happy life yeah yeah yeah because
80 of relationships are in this oh sorry
80 of divorces are initiated by women
right by women I mean it's no surprise
guys would be terrified isn't it yeah
Paul just going back to what you said
about
um you know like women that flee from
men and will make up this story and
stuff like that in the UK it is so easy
to do that it's so easy to say you know
um I'm in this situation like for
example that person that you know they
said I was with a Muslim guy he done
this this and this is so easy for women
to do that for women to go to shelters
and for men it's like it's they're not
even heard like at all well it's cousin
Family Court I'm learning about this now
so I might butcher it but it's up to the
discretion of a judge
um so normally like if you go to
Criminal Court you you have to convince
a jury and that's a little and it's
based on evidence we're in family court
it's based on a balance of probabilities
so they're not even 100 sure he's guilty
in the UK this is even before the court
like yeah yeah like if you could I don't
really know like the lines and stuff but
if you for example said to your doctor I
mean this even though you might not be
you could say I'm in this relationship
this person is like you know domestic
violence I have a child you can leave
that night and then they'll take you to
like a refuge or something like it's so
easy for women I'm not saying that
there's not women out there that
actually do need that because they do
but there's also women that are taking
advantage of that and once you get to
that point you can get benefits you can
get housing like there's so much more
but before the court I'm saying like
before the court and they kick him out
of the house because that's what he was
telling me he was saying you first go to
either a teacher or a doctor and then
they take you to the women's shelter and
they tell you what to say and then one
call um to the police they have the
women's shelter instructs you on what to
say to the police so he's gone basically
yeah the police can take them the next
day yeah yeah and so um one like there's
one guy who got one call and it was I
forgot what exactly the words he said
but it was basically like get out of the
house and he still has to pay for the
mortgage on the house because it's in
his name and then he slapped with 1500
in child support a month easily and then
he lost his job because he was so yeah
you know I mean he just lost his kids
and everything he owned I have one
client that basically
um he built the whole you know financial
situation the wife was staying home with
the kids and he came home one day early
from work and his wife was with another
guy and you know the guy was like
running out the back door whatever but
what's interesting is that she ended up
getting the whole house like almost full
custody of the kids and like totally
ruined his life but he didn't do
anything wrong right just the way the
system is set up and that doesn't mean
like oh everyone needs to go mgtow now
and don't ever get married but that
really like calls into question here
that was not even something he did you
know he didn't do anything wrong but the
courts are going to side with the woman
in most cases in the western world yeah
and that's it's hard because
there's not really a way to avoid it out
here because even the guy that I talked
to the other day he wasn't legally
married it was just exactly you don't
even need to be married like it's just
it's so easy like as soon as you go
through the doctor that that day they
will send you to like
the
do you know someone that's happened to
yeah that's why tell me tell me what
happened
um so I know somebody that was in just
in a normal relationship no problem
whatever but they needed housing
yeah like there's nothing to do with a
partner so they just created their own
partner in their head got into a refuge
no way waited a year was in temporary
housing
and then got into a flat so don't even
need like any type of evidence you don't
need evidence like now nowadays they're
cracking onto it more but I know back
then it was easy if I said I'm gonna run
it they don't even need to know the guy
if I just and I just literally they
don't even need to be a fake person and
I'm not saying that I haven't done dust
or live at home I'm just saying example
right people but that's how easy it is
in the UK like people take advantage of
the system
so yeah the number of abuse allegations
increased uh 200 percent when they
implemented that law I think it was
2013. um so yeah because like you're
getting hit you okay yeah not saying
that that doesn't happen though I'm not
being insensitive but I'm just being
real do you guys think okay if the roles
were reversed and we had those
repercussions for being with men yeah
would you change your behavior I I want
to talk to anyone you want to talk to
anyone you know what's funny I think I'm
I'm curious I haven't heard from you yet
so I want to hear eggshells I would be
walking on eggshells I would be so
paranoid it'd be paranoid to the point
where it's like it's not even a point in
talking to anyone I'll just do me focus
on me someone comes my way they come my
way I wouldn't even go out looking for
people because I would be so scared of
what could come from it legally some
guys
um put ring all over their apartment so
they can't say that anything that was
consensual like wasn't consensual yeah
but then wouldn't that be um
like they're recording it without your
content I have no idea if that's legal
yeah you can't Record sex acts yeah
that's where they draw the line right so
like I I advise clients to have like you
know at least to come outside your house
or in situations where it is legal so
you can show I actually spoke to a
lawyer about this because because I've
been sleeping a lot of girls I said how
do I protect myself and he said I'll
just send a text did you have a good
time I was it that's not guaranteed
they're going to respond even if they
did right so an objective empirical
account that shows like this person's
living on good terms and this and that
I've never had any accusation luckily
with all these girls but I have plenty
of clients that have and a lot of times
like I mentioned before it's because the
person cheated and then they just want
to save the marriage and it's like you
know there's no consequence for doing
that really if the girl is lying which
is unfortunate but I think just proceed
with caution is a
I don't know like in some countries it's
a bit more strict I feel like even
though you the UK might say some of
these things I haven't actually heard
them until today can I just say
something also I think also in the west
and it's naturally right a lot of a lot
of men go after
these type of women and they they like
them it's attractive these type of women
that will
how would I say the word
crazy no no they will F them up okay
yeah because they're attractive they're
sexy they're whatever it is but you
don't understand you turned around like
you created that monster woman have to
be looking that certain way wait that
certain way blah blah blah she needs
and then this woman become your worst
enemy because this woman is a gold
digger you have to keep maintaining her
looks her you know going out every night
in these type of restaurants and she
will use you and abuse you but we a man
most of the time are attracted to this
type of woman and they complain about
what these women do for them but they
don't honor a lot of nice girls that
they don't look like 10 out of 10. it's
the same reverse too right like women
don't want a nice guy 100 it's it's
natural people
exactly it is attractive I also we do I
also think that man you really don't
know what someone's gonna do when
they're when they're scorned when
they're pissed off and I think you can
see see a different side of people when
there's a breakup but that's what I'm
saying and that's the thing it's not
that like women are worse than men or
men are worse than wait it's but it's
that women are given the tools to
destroy men if they so want to yeah
interesting to see what type of world
would be living in when that's been
reversed yeah well I mean you could go
back a hundred years ago it wasn't the
no-fault divorce started in
90s 70s I don't remember but 100 years
ago it wasn't like that oh look at the
east east let's see that was one of the
problems because when men did have that
power Society saw some men is abusing it
so you know there was a natural sense
you know to kind of balance it but like
I said it's just the pendulum has gone
too far and I think what's happened is
people have just lost their balls people
are not courageous enough to say enough
you know men and women come together and
say it's enough it's gone too far
everybody is suffering how can we do it
together and we've created this
polarized world where everyone's on each
other's backs you know men against women
black against white rich against Paul
and no one's come together and say what
kind of society do we want to live in
and how courageous do we need to be to
create it it's not going to be perfect
and there's always going to be losers
but we need to create this because
everyone's suffering but no one's doing
that and it feels like society and the
powers that are be have created this
like what you just said pal I mean the
fact that you've got rumble on standby
just shows there's a lot of I know you
have a lot of your detractors a lot of
your hates I get it but there is
something really important about what
you're trying to say same way Kevin
Samuels God Rest his soul there's a lot
of stuff that people are trying to say
but the minute they say they're shut
down but we need to hear his point of
view as many of you know I was just bad
talk and to monetize on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible